I told you
I'm on vacation
while I'm on vacation I'ma just float
come here Mr Parker
Marcus and Emily Parker you have failed
to notify your airline that you are
registered sex offenders
what the hell is wrong with you
look at us all together again we just
wanted to give you guys a real honeymoon
just found this crawling under our table
he's crawling
it's a prodigy it's amazing
gonna place this nice
you get us in here you didn't tell him
they gonna be long gone by the time I
get into my birthday you must be Mr
Parker apologies for the change in
schedule Mr Young is invited you for
drinks all of you gas I need you to be
really cool you do that for me
[Music]
[Applause]
look who you're talking to when have we
ever not been cool
it's released from San Quentin
I got you the best wedding present what
why does this coconut taste Cokey
because it's your mom it's really kind
of beautiful if you think about it no
listen to her picture thing's going at
all it's cool Marcus is cool we're
floating right
get your hands off my wife
ever since he showed up he turned this
relaxing family vacation to total chaos
who does that
[Music]
we have been through him
why don't we just go back I knew it
chicken it's only one thing left to do
sir
[Applause]
I've never seen that much water come up
a person before did I throw up a lot
your butthole threw up bud
[Music]
thank you